uh you were talking about a couple guys
on the internet i asked this from
michael i'm just curious to know what if
you can have any comments on it or not
uh
names that are coming up
uh recently jimmy calandra is coming up
uh i think you and him did something
together
a light's coming up johnny russo we've
had him on as well
uh
who what do you think about some of
these guys and what they're doing on
social i asked michael the same question
i did i know jimmy calandra he's a
friend of mine and i did have him in my
place he came down he was going to get a
hotel room i said listen bro i'm living
alone you want to just come and live
with me i just got my dog with me yeah
yeah so we live together for about four
five days
and uh he came on my show i did a show
with him we had some left like we're
doing now i'm talking
and then one or two people i don't wanna
name names but one or two people
exploded
because he was arguing with one of those
names or a couple of those names you're
talking about
and uh they were saying that i
encouraged him to do that which i did i
didn't encourage him i i encouraged him
when i talked to them i said there's a
lot of out there
put it on the side don't get into it
they want to do this
they want you
so they can get hits and they could get
subscribers and they could get views so
they try to get into an argument with
you once you're going back and forth
you're feeding right into what they want
just put them on the burn but jimmy has
a little bit of a temper and he didn't
he exchanged back and forth with them a
couple of times
and uh
and they blamed me for that which it
doesn't matter to me i don't care
and uh
so i don't bother with some of those
names you just mentioned i don't even
bother with them i did bother with one
because one of them this they like kid
when i came home and i got out of prison
he threw me a couple of dollars right
away first guy
so
i try to
reciprocate by saying he's a good guy
he's a tough guy he's this he's that you
try to help him with his show and all
that
then he wanted me to come on and do
certain things and i didn't want to be
bothered with that
i'm not i'm not i'm a truthful person if
i do something
listen i take credit for that or
make maybe that's not the word credit
but i take my my responsibilities for
what i did
i mean i got people that'll call me i
got people's kids
that murders i'm involved and i spoke to
them
people's families i spoke to them
this is what happened this is what it
was this is what the truth is because a
lot of them stuff they hear is their
lies
in other words i'm involved in three
mafia awards 19 murders i didn't go out
and i never got up one morning and said
listen i'm gonna go kill somebody that
was part of the mafia
[Music]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]